[Music]
i'm catholic who here is catholic
anybody all right
it's about one-ninth of you
i see what's happening uh yeah today is
ash wednesday if you didn't know ash
wednesday marks the beginning of the
christian observance known as lent
now during lent it's traditional to give
up
certain luxuries or habits things you
like to do you give them up for lent i
thought it might be kind of interesting
to see what kinds of things our own
audience has decided to give up
for lent okay first up
check this out giving up selling his own
plasma to buy widespread panic concert
tickets
that takes guts
check
it's real
it's a real sacrifice
check this one out giving up trying to
get the new york times to publish his
erotic
poetry yeah
it's good stuff
it's good stuff always has a rhyme for
nantucket uh
check this one out giving up hitting on
younger guys at the food court
[Music]
this one of course check this out giving
up having sex with supermodels
those days are
over there's this one check this out
giving up riding his vintage unicycle
tour
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
unicycle insecure mime uh
check this one out giving up telling
neighborhood kids that he killed adolf
[Music]
[Applause]
hitler he tried to get away but i did oh
just now they're telling him what's
going on all right all right
check this one out giving up any hope of
ever seeing his chin again
[Music]
congratulations all of you for what
you've given up